[Музика]
привіт мене звуть Ольга Менма і ласкаво
просимо на урок англійської мови, лижі, які ми
сьогодні будемо тренувати, це
монолог, який добре говорить, коли я побачив, чого
я буду вчити своїх учнів 11
класу, чого б  будьте
для них найбільш вигідними з точки зору монологічної промови,
ласкаво просимо до світу дорослих, світу
публічних розмов, будь то університет,
ваша перша робота або публічний захід, на якому
ви попросили всього десять перед групою
людей, і щоби промовити
якийсь час  тому мені було дано завдання
провести невелику доповідь приблизно на десять хвилин
для моїх колег-викладачів, і
тема, яку мені дали, це технології та
освіта. Я буду відвертий із вами після
багатьох років роботи на різних
роботах та викладання англійської мови.
Я все ще борюся з цим  Мені знадобилося близько трьох
днів, щоб попрацювати над текстом,
щоб відредагувати його, щоб вивчити його, щоб попрактикуватися, щоб побачити,
скільки часу мені знадобиться, і
дійсно запам’ятати всі аспекти, такі
як швидкість того, як я
збираюся  О, що я буду носити, як я
буду стояти і що я буду робити
своїми руками, я збираюся поділитися деякими з
цих навичок з вами сьогодні, і так,
я відтворю фактично те, що
я  розповіла моїм колегам, чи ви готові
правильно, давайте почнемо, привіт, мене звуть
олдермен Мартін, і перш ніж ми почнемо, дозвольте
мені поставити вам питання, що технологія в
освіті
на краще чи на гірше, давайте подивимося, що ви
думаєте, поставте мені великий палець вгору,
якщо ви думаєте, що технології
є причиною  хороша і корисна річ, дякую
і великий палець вниз, якщо ви вважаєте, що
технологічна індикація не дає нам
переваг, добре зроблено,
дозвольте мені поділитися з вами деякими своїми ідеями,
які я викладаю вже п’ятнадцять років,
і мені завжди було важко, коли я запитую
себе  це запитання, наприклад, ви
даєте своїм учням завдання, які ви бачите, як вони
використовують пристрої, у них є Wi-Fi, у них є
комп’ютери, у них є телефони, і
вони відкривають різні вкладки, вони
шукають інформацію в Google, вони шукатимуть
інформацію, накопичують її  проаналізуйте це, а
потім створіть кілька дійсно крутих проектів,
і ви думаєте, що вау технологія та
освіта є корисним інструментом, або ви даєте
учням завдання, що їм надається
однаковий час доступу до Інтернет-
пристроїв, комп’ютерів, телефонів, і що
ви бачите, як вони публікують фотографії  в
Instagram або записуєте нові тенденції в
tik-tok, і ви думаєте, що
ці технології відволікають для освіти
, і це проблема,
як викладачі, ми ніколи не дізнаємося, що ми
повинні робити, що є найкращим для наших
студентів, тому я  Я ставлю собі це
питання, технології в
освіті, я роблю це чи уникаю
, гм, коли у вас є запитання, що
ви робите зараз
не вдалося,
це дало мені доступ до сотень
статей, але деякі з них були
ще до того, як деякі з них були б проти
хороших новин, це питання є дискусійним,
і я дізнався три основні
речі  Пошук у Google і аналіз усієї
цієї інформації Технологія номер один
в освіті корисна,
наші студенти мають доступ до величезної
бази інформації зображення зображення зображення
відео різні ресурси, щоб знайти
cyclopædia правильна освіта і
технології можуть бути складними школами
може закінчитися кібер-залякування або
шахрайство  простіше, коли у вас
є пристрій та доступ до інформації,
однак, поглянувши на ці два
пункти, я зрозумів, що ставити це
питання, чи корисні технології в
освіті, чи це величезний
недолік, не є правильним питанням, яке
потрібно ставити до третього.  ми повинні
пам’ятати, що технології не сповільнюються,
вони насправді розвиваються, і вони
зростають, якщо ви вчитель у 2020
році, переважна більшість ваших учнів
народитимуться після 2020 року, що означає, що вони є
цифровими уродженцями, вони народилися з
доступом до своїх батьків  або їхні власні
пристрої до Інтернету та вся
інформація, доступна 24/7 з будь-якого місця,
коли у вас є ac  підключення до
Інтернету є проблемою для всіх нас, це
більше виклик, це відповідальність
і наша програма, як вчителі, як
вихователі, щоб знати для себе, як
використовувати це для наших та їхніх переваг,
уявімо школу, яка стикається з кібер-
залякуванням, що б  типова
реакція вчителя позбутися технологій уникати
проблем немає технологій немає проблем ні
не працює, як тільки ваш учень залишає
цю міхур безпеки, яку ви створюєте
в школі, вважаючи, що ви робите
це якнайкраще, вони вступають у
життя непідготовленими і  стикаються з набагато
більшими проблемами, які вони могли б, якби
ми навчили їх правильно користуватися пристроями
та інформацією,
тому що як викладачі ми
несемо відповідальність навчити наших студентів тому,
як залишитися у світі
цифрових уродженців, як користуватися пристроями
інформація про те, як підвищити свою цифрову
грамотність та перетворитися на тих, хто навчається протягом усього життя,
використовуючи технології та освіту,
привіт, о, привіт усім  Мені дуже шкода,
я дуже нервую,
я вперше розмовляю з вами, але це буде дуже
цікаво, будь ласка, допоможіть мені, дякую,
дякую, дякую, давайте почнемо з
питання, як ви думаєте
, чи хороші технології в освіті  або погано, добре
так, поставте мені великий палець вгору, якщо ви думаєте, що
це добре, о, дякую, дякую,
і великий палець вниз, якщо ви думаєте, що
це погано, о, дякую, дякую, я
викладав 15 років, і ми використовували
технології на уроках і  У мене завжди були
проблеми з цим, тому що я ніколи не знав,
чи мої учні використовують це належним
чином чи неправильно Мені шкода,
наприклад, якщо учні використовують мобільні телефони
для дослідження, я завжди вражений,
коли бачу дитину  хто відкриває кілька
вкладок, вони шукають різноманітні джерела
цікавої інформації і водночас,
і я думаю, вау, вау, технології
в класі, що теж цінно, але
коли ви бачите студента, який робить
тік-ток або публікує в Instagram, я думаю,
о це  це жахливо  жахливе
руйнування так, і моя робота як
викладача полягає в тому, щоб робити те, що є найкращим для моїх
студентів з точки зору технологій, і я
не знаю, що є найкращим, тому я
зробив те, що сьогодні роблять усі, я
погуглив питання і довгу історію зробив
коротким гуглим  не пройшло добре, і
якщо ви погуглите це питання, виявиться,
що ви знайдете сотні статей,
які переконливо обґрунтовують обидві сторони
цієї проблеми, тож тепер отримайте їх, але
ключове повідомлення, яке я отримав, полягає в тому, що ця тема є
дискусійною, і є три основні
речі, які  ми повинні знати про
технологію ммм номер один технологія
може бути небезпечною. У школі такі речі, як
кібер-залякування, академічна нечесність,
тому що шахрайство в Інтернеті може
бути легше,
а тут мінне поле технологій, і ми
повинні бути обережними. Друге, що ми
знаємо, це те, що технології можуть  бути
безмежно цінним, це може сприяти
навчанню студентів, надаючи доступ до
величезного резервуара інформації,
я так хвилююся, вибачте, тому номер два ми
знаємо  w технологія може бути корисною те, що
ми знаємо, це ознака технології, погана
технологічна освіта — це добре, і,
схоже, ми ще не близькі до відповіді
на питання, але ми рухаємося до
третього пункту, який трохи прояснить це,
третя, що ми знаємо  полягає в тому, що
технології не сповільнюються, а прискорюються
щодня, і якщо ви студент у 2020 році,
ви згорите десь після 2000 року,
а те, що робить сто відсотків
студентів,
їх називають поколінням Z, яке зазвичай
називають цифровими тубільцями, і це
термін розповідає про всі їхні основні якості,
що вони ніколи не відчували жодного слова
без Інтернету, мобільних телефонів без
доступу до всього світу, і якщо
це так, наші студенти,
вибачте, технологія залишилася від пристрою,
ніж у них, і більше від
середовища, яке вони
наприклад, якщо школа
стикається з проблемами кібер-залякування, скажімо, вони можуть
вирішити заборонити технології, тому що вони
думають, що проблема зрозуміла і
технології мають негативний вплив  t щодо
навчання студентів, і рішення
просте,
без технологій, без проблем, але
рішення є лише тимчасовим, якщо
врахувати, що згодом дзвонить
дзвоник, і студенти залишать
клас, матимуть мобільні телефони та вийдуть
із міхура безпеки, для якого ми
створили  їх, а потім у цей момент
вони опиняться в невідомому
цифровому середовищі з тими ж
небезпеками, але цього разу недосвідчені та
непідготовлені, тому, коли ми подивимося на
запитання ще раз, воно є більш корисним чи
шкідливим для наших студентів, ми розуміємо, що
це неправильне запитання  нам, тому
що не має значення,
корисніша чи шкідлива технологія для наших учнів,
пам’ятайте лише про дві речі, дві речі
номер один, оскільки школа, викладачі, наша
відповідальність полягає в тому, щоб робити те, що є найкращим
для наших учнів, і наші учні мають
пристрій у кишені  це найбільш
цінно і небезпечно, тому
стає зрозумілим, що використання технологій
у класі є меншим вибором і
більше  відповідальність, тому що
викладачі носять наставників, а це означає, що
ми зобов’язані підготувати студентів
до проблем, пов’язаних із цифровим народом,
оскільки вчителями ми несемо відповідальність за
можливість надати учням
можливість розвивати свої літературні
навички та стати незалежними
учнями на все життя о, я думаю, що я забув  сказати, що одна
технологія корисна для технології,
має багато недоліків, а три так,
це неправильне питання, тепер вибачте, я
забув сказати, що вибачте, дуже дякую,
до побачення, дорогі студенти, оскільки ви,
ймовірно, здогадуєтеся, що рішення є легким,
практика робить його ідеальним, коли ви
враховуючи завдання публічного
виступу, дайте собі належну
кількість часу, щоб підготуватися до практичної практики,
але є п’ять речей,
які я зробив правильно і навмисно зробив неправильно.
Ви ввійдете
в контакт зі своєю аудиторією,
ви встановите це чудове взаєморозуміння,
яке gi  якщо ви маєте доступ до їхнього
правильного слухання, не уникайте цього, завжди робіть це, номер
два, пам’ятайте, наскільки швидко ви
говорите, наскільки швидко ви говорите, це
важливо, якщо ви робите це занадто повільно, ваші
накази можуть спати, якщо ви робите це занадто
швидко, тоді ваш  аудиторія не
зможе слідкувати за вашим повідомленням,
добре уникайте величезних пауз, хоча, наприклад, ммм,
що приносить всі нещастя, повірте мені,
як тільки ваші руки пам’ятайте, що
є деякі жести, які ви можете використовувати,
деякі вказують,
але намагайтеся не возитися з  ваші
руки, які дійсно відволікають, показують вашу
нервозність, незалежно від того, наскільки ви нервуєте
, будь ласка, не вибачайтеся, будь ласка, залиште
це за кімнатою, де ви виголошуєте
свою промову, намагайтеся виглядати впевнено,
дихайте, до
речі, дуже важливо, якщо я продовжую
виступати стоячи  тільки в
одному виді спорту він може бути нудним, дайте
вашій аудиторії трохи розділити їхню
увагу, спробуйте рухатися, робіть це впевнено
і повільно, що приверне їхню
увагу  Зверніть увагу на те, що ви говорите, так,
рухатися та змінювати паузи – це абсолютно
нормально. Ще один важливий момент: я
намагаюся підтримувати зоровий контакт
з аудиторією, якщо ви продовжуєте дивитися вниз
або вгору або в сторони, що насправді
не залучає вашу аудиторію  у своїй
доповіді я формую свою аудиторію, даючи
можливість голосувати, ставлячи мені великий палець вгору або
великий палець вниз, і найгірше, що ви
можете зробити, це читати, якщо ви дотримуєтеся своїх
нотаток і просто читаєте, повірте мені, це не
спрацює правильно,
давайте  подивіться та узагальніть наші найкращі
5 або що робити, коли ви виступаєте на
публічному виступі номер один, будь ласка,
уявіть себе,
щоб підтримувати зоровий контакт з аудиторією
номер три, контролюйте темп своєї
розмови,
це не повинно бути надто повільним або занадто швидким
наступним кроком  дозвольте собі переміщатися
по кімнаті, де ви говорите, і,
звісно, остання спроба залучити ау
иторію, ви точно зробите це, до
тримуючись усіх інших порад, які я р
бив, го
осуючи великим пальцем вгору чи вниз та за
итуючи вас  рішливі запитання, які зазвичай
працюють
[Музика]
і п'ять не будь ласка, ніколи не робіть цього
номер один найгірше, що коли-небудь читали,
будь ласка, не читайте, будь ласка, не читайте аудиторія не
слухатиме вас так, незалежно від того, наскільки
ви нервуєте  повірте мені, я нервував, коли
розмовляв, будь ласка, не вибачайтеся
за те, що ви сказали за те, що
ви сказали, за що як ви нервуєте
всі величезні паузи і дійсно не
працюють уникайте гри руками,
справді ви впевнені  ваша нервозність, і
як тільки ви почнете це робити,
аудиторія вас не слухає, і останнє
, що я робив неправильно, я
іноді робив занадто швидко, знову
накази не вловлюють ваше повідомлення, тепер,
ймовірно, вони перестануть вас слухати
на номері хвилини  три-чотири з ваших
виступів
[Музика]
Я бажаю вам усім успіхів у ваших
публічних виступах, пам'ятайте, що практика
досконала,
я сподіваюся, що наша п'ятеро, тому що робити, а що
не робити, нам доведеться готуватися незалежно
від події, незалежно від того, як  велика ваша
аудиторія  хто є або хто вони, ти
завжди будеш готовий до публічної розмови
удачі до зустрічі на наступному уроці до побачення
[Музика]
ти